- This is Rene Magritte's
Menaced Assassin from 1927.
In preparation for the exhibition,
we did some treatment,
and also some technical examinations.
One of the techniques we used
for examining the painting
was infrared light,
and that typically shows underdrawing.
In some cases you can see details,
where, for instance, in the toe of the man
standing in the center,
the table leg actually was
painted over the figure.
Particularly in 1927,
when he painted a lot of
large paintings, you can
really see he was working
very quickly and economically to get these
big images ready for his gallery show.
In the transmitted light,
where you actually shine
a light from behind
the canvas, so you can see
details in the brushwork.
You can see he used a much finer brush
for the details in the faces,
and in the case of the three
small heads in the center,
he also used a kind of varnish
to accentuate the faces.
We also saw that particularly
in the black paint,
our theory is that Magritte
used a commercial paint
to mix in with the blacks to
make them more rich and glossy,
to accent details, in particular,
in the shoulders of the
figures on the left and right.
When it was first acquired by MoMA,
the conservators described
the surface as moldy,
and they thought that
this patchy appearance
was due to actual mold contamination.
We actually discovered that this kind of
patchy appearance is mainly
due to zinc in the ground.
The commercial canvases that Magritte used
had a thick layer of zinc
in the priming layer,
and over time, especially
in a thin paint layer,
the zinc can actually come to the surface,
and that seems to have
happened in this case.
The treatment and examination
took about a year,
and now, you really get to see Magritte
as is intended, with the
palette looking very fresh
and differences in the nuances
of the brushwork visible,
and all this is now very apparent
after the recent conservation treatment.